welcome back everybody we've got some
important information for our local
seniors
health care plans can get really
complicated i know you know that i want
to introduce you
to a local medicare benefits advisor
that is dedicated to helping you
navigate
this year's enrollment period
[Music]
hi my name is darren whitehour i am a
gerontologist and the owner of the ecos
medicare solutions agency
and we're based here in las vegas as a
local company that helps seniors
with their medicare so the annual
enrollment period begins in october 15th
and runs through december 7th
every year this is the period of time
that any senior
or anybody on medicare can change their
plans
or get a plan so it's just an
opportunity to
do everything you want to do or anything
you want to do with your medicare
advantage or your medicare supplement
plans
every year everyone should get a review
of their plan whether they want to keep
it or not
because the companies are the carriers
insurance carriers come out with changes
and those changes should be relayed to
the customers if they don't know about
it they could be missing out on
opportunities like
dental or better drug plans or things
like that it doesn't mean we had to
change a plan
it just means we want to educate you on
the changes in your plan
the easiest way is just to call us and
we set an appointment
we're happy to come out to your home
we're happy to have you come to our
office
actually you know we've met people in a
lot of different places whether
you know from mcdonald's to starbucks to
a park bench
you know it's it's kind of wherever our
clients feel the most comfortable
that's where we're going to come meet
you we've got a highly trained staff
along with myself and and we're here to
help you locally so you get a friendly
face
to talk to if you need help if you miss
your enrollment period
it's called lock-in time and you could
be stuck
all the way till the next january first
or the next annual enrollment period
we do have reasons that people can
change okay
there's a there's something called open
enrollment that goes from
uh january 1st to march 31st it's not
advertised but it is available for
people or our members to change one time
a year
and then we have special enrollment
periods for chronic chronic special
needs
people in dual special needs medicare
medicaid
clients we encourage our seniors to come
out and
and have an agent evaluate their needs
and evaluate
uh what the new plan was offered them
there's always at least one change i
know that they always get
mailed a change of benefits from the
carrier
but maybe they won't understand what
that actually means so we sit down with
them we go line by line with them
and explain what the what the
opportunities for the next year are
typically there's no losses but there
could be it's just very important for
them to
to know exactly how their plan works or
even just to get a refresher
all right call ecos medicare solutions
at 702-277-4753 or just visit their
website ecosmedicaresolutions.com we'll
be right back